Devil Ray Devil Ray wow it looks
[Music]
cool Mother Nature has gifted me with so
many incredible encounters and animals
up close and these are some of my
favorite moments from this series a real
highlight for me in the
[Music]
galapagus:
but these guys can rack up enough body
heat on land to survive a 60-minute swim
any longer and the cold will paralyze
their muscles and they're not just up
against the clock they're up against the
elements the best feeding grounds lie
beyond the surf and out to sea I want to
film The iguanas as they enter a set of
Breakers the locals call the washing
machine
down on the rocky seabed are thick
carpets of seaweed this is the prize
awaiting any iguana tough enough to make
the journey they are tough little
animals for the six episodes we did 219
days in the field the longest period we
did for any one episode was for the
Patagonia Puma episode and that was 51
days you see it oh wow just did yeah
just it just it right
here that's spaka
Spa wow that is good to see her the last
time I saw her she was a cub and now she
is a massive adult with two Cubs of her
own my favorite destination from this
series uh has got to be Antarctica it's
big it's wild and it makes you feel very
very
small they're lining up here they come
they're making a
way whoa they're rolling it they've just
rolled it off I thought wave washing
killer whales would just make a wave and
wash the seal off but they've got this
whole set of different strategies the
b1s need all these strategies because in
Antarctica Anything Can
Happen who there's a hbag whale right
here oh wow the hb's right in the middle
of
it two humback whales just came out of
nowhere that can't be a coincidence that
the hunt back's turned up
now they must be going over to try and
disrupt the hunt I mean that has been
recorded before huntbach whales trying
to disrupt kilwell
hunts in the bosana wild doog episode my
favorite moment for sure was when the
pack would rally so the pack was made up
of 11 adults and every morning before
they'd go out to hunt um they'd be at
the Den where they had their 14
unbelievably cute pups the little Tails
make my heart hurt when I think about
them okay yeah I've got dogs coming
in coming in
fast
greeting African wild doogs are super
social and communicates through an array
of unique and complex calls
whoa they're all very pleased to see
each
other there is often a plan uh but
animals don't read the script so that
just completely goes out the window
usually on day
one oh dear ah don't get
stung oh this is just weird it's like a
giant jellyfish Invasion the current's
changed and it's brought with it just
this wave of jelly jellyfish feels like
in some crazy computer game and this is
the Dodge the jellyfish
level jellyfish have been around for
half a billion years scientists think
the jellyfish population is booming
because they tolerate climate change
better than other sea creatures it's a
worrying
sign oh there's a mate and it is
huge okay let's going nice and
slow well these Manas are a bigger
Bolder relation of the devil ray oh it's
letting me get really
close the name Manta comes from the
Spanish word for
cloak can really see
why looks like a big spaceship turning
around why I can see its eye they have
huge brains the biggest of any fish it
might explain why this one is so
inquisitive lantis coming back around
belly
up one of the things I'm most proud of
of animals up close is that in each
episode we celebrate uh a conservation
success story there are some incredible
people around the world doing their
utmost to turn this thing around and
show that you know if you give nature
the chance it will come back on an
unbelievable
scale we're heading to zanga National
Park to film a forest elephant tuska
look at
that Tatiana wants to show me what these
elephants are up
against
jeez heavy 27th of November this year
that was like a week
ago second of o October last
year you can see the machete marks where
it's been cut off the
elephant guess I didn't expect it to be
Al so recent there's an elephant there
that was poached last week and that
absolute
Beauty less than a year ago over 12,000
Forest elephants are killed for their
Ivory every year if this continues
Extinction could be less than a decade
away Tatiana and the Eco guards are
fighting back over the past 4 years
poaching incidents have dropped by more
than
80% it gives me a small glimmer of
hope this is one of the biggest and
rarest elephants in Africa a forest
elephant tusker huge males with TUS tus
that sweep down to the
floor look at the size of its
[Music]
tusks a tuska this big is an incredibly
rare sight these elephants aren't just
part of the forest they are the forest
they keep it healthy they shape the
landscape it's magical to think this
tuska has been secretly roaming the
forest for over half a century defending
his territory and bading
poaches I hope people come away from
watching animals up close learn more
about the threats that we humans are
causing on the natural world but I also
hope that they come away feeling excited
and
[Music]
inspired